bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin en séance un débat sur les
pesticides et leurs effets sur la santé
et l'environnement
ce débat qui s'est tenu le 23 janvier
fait suite à un rapport intitulé
pesticides vers le risque zéro qui a été
élaboré en octobre 2012 par la mission
commune d'information sur les pesticides
ce rapport à bord de 18 thématiques
comme par exemple la question des
productions agricoles ou encore la
commercialisation ou bien le rôle des
collectivités
il s'agit de trouver les moyens de
réduire l'usagé des pesticides dans
l'agriculture en france mais aussi plus
largement en europe tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle pour ce débat sur
les pesticides et leurs effets sur la
santé et l'environnement très bonne
matinée à tous sur public sénat
l'ordre du jour mes chers collègues
appellent le débat sur les pesticides et
leur impact sur la santé et
l'environnement demande de la mission
commune d'information sur les pesticides
et leur impact sur la santé et
l'environnement
la parole est à madame sophie primas
présidente de la mission commune
d'information sur les pesticides et leur
impact sur la santé et l'environnement
bonjour
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre
madame la rapporteure chaire nicole mes
chers collègues je dois vous dire en
début d'intervention que je prendrais
l'ensemble de mon temps de parole c'est
10 minutes puis les 6 minutes qui
m'était proposé ensuite et je n'aurais
interviendrait pas une seconde fois en
ce début de débat le devoir de la
présidente de la mission d'information
de vous rappeler quelques dates quelques
chiffres et quelques événements
concernant les travaux de la mission
mais aussi celui d' évoquer l'esprit qui
a animé ces travaux est de me permettre
si vous me le permettez à titre
individuel d'exprimer mes convictions
forgée au cours de ses six mois de
présidence
cette mission a été créée à
l'instigation de ma collègue nicole
bonnefoy en raison notamment de
l'actualité qui a marqué son département
et je voudrais à ce moment de mon
intervention adressé au nom de la
mission
mes plus sincères remerciements à
monsieur paul françois ainsi qu'aux
membres de son association phyto
victimes
je pense à jacky ferrand je sais qu'ils
sont tous les deux là dans le public les
remercier pour l'accueil qu'ils nous ont
réservé en charente pour la grande
sincérité de leurs propos pour leur
dignité dans une épreuve pourtant
extrêmement difficile je dois vous dire
que leur témoignage nous a certes
bouleversé mais nous a surtout conduit à
traiter ce sujet en dehors de tout
esprit partisan en toute responsabilité
et dans l'intérêt général je voudrais
donc les remercier et les saluer
particulièrement je dois signer à
souligner que notre mission a bénéficié
tout au long de ces travaux de l'intérêt
marqué des sénateurs issus de l'ensemble
des groupes politiques
je les remercie également pour leur
travail leur implication et l'excellente
ambiance qui a prévalu à ces travaux
cette mission a débuté ses travaux en
mars 2012 et a immédiatement décidé de
limiter son champ d'investigation aux
impacts des pesticides sur la santé des
utilisateurs professionnels ou non et de
ceux qui se trouvent en amont de leur
utilisation
traiter des questions relatives à
l'environnement ou à l'alimentation
excédé ce qu'il était réaliste
d'investiguer en quelques mois nous
avons donc l'espoir que ce volet sera
traité dans une prochaine mission
d'information notre mission s'est
achevée en octobre 2012 au terme de six
mois de travaux après avoir mené à peu
près 95 audition au sénat et en province
au moyen de visites effectuées dans cinq
départements la charente lot-et-garonne
le morbihan le rhône et le val de marne
à maisons alfort avec une journée de
travail à l'enm cesse l'ensemble de ce
travail représentant un dialogue de plus
de 100 heures avec plus de 200 personnes
cette mission s'est achevée avec
l'adoption à l'unanimité d'un rapport
comprenant plus d'une centaine de
recommandations
cette unanimité recherché par tous les
membres de notre mission était un signal
fort que nous souhaitions ensemble
adresser aux acteurs concernés
jardiniers du dimanche distributeurs
professionnels ou distributeur grand
public industriel agents des
collectivités territoriales et bien sûr
agriculteurs les propositions de la
mission sont d'importance naturellement
très variable et font l'objet pour
certaines d'une adhésion plus ou moins
marquée de chacun de nous en fonction de
nos sensibilités
certains auraient souhaité aller plus
loin plus vite
d'autres avec quelques appréhensions
mais nous souhaitions avoir une position
commune forte pour faire entendre notre
message unanime la santé doit être au
coeur de notre action
nos travaux d'été ponctuée d'une
actualité souvent riche qui a souligné
le caractère parfois polémique je dirais
passionnel des termes abordés par notre
mission ainsi à titre d'exemple et entre
autres choses au mois d'octobre 2012
la publication de travaux d'un
universitaire sur les effets de la santé
des ogm dont les médias se sont très
largement fait l'écho a conduit
plusieurs membres de la mission a
assisté à l'audition commune de lanne
cesse organisée sur le sujet controversé
de la nature d évaluation des dangers et
des risques de ces produits pour la
santé
ce thème de réflexion est et connexes à
celui de la mission est illustré un
schéma parfaitement identique à celui
portant sur la dangerosité des
pesticides
d'une part des travaux scientifiques par
nature partielles faisant l'objet de
controverses
d'autre part le manque cruel
d'informations d'épidémiologie de
toxicologie d'expo logis rendant
impossible une analyse globale et
contradictoires dans ce cas il est
toujours difficile de distinguer pour
nous le fondement scientifique réelle de
l'emballement partisans non dénué
d'intérêt par ailleurs cela laisse le
champ libre à toutes les interprétations
des plus rassurantes au plus alarmiste
la fameuse fabrique du doute
avant de laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur madame bonne foi pour la
présentation du rapport et des
recommandations
je souhaite d'abord la remercier elle
aussi vivement et chaleureusement pour
le travail considérable qu'elle a
fournis et l'esprit cordiale et
républicains avec lequel nous avons fait
et kit simple constat adoptée par le
bureau ont servi de socle à la centaine
de recommandations qui ont été proposées
et voter
première constatation les dangers et les
risques des pesticides pour la santé
sont sous-évaluées en effet les modèles
maladies liées à l'utilisation de
produits phytosanitaires sont de deux
ordres
elles sont soit la conséquence directe
d'un accident et dans ce cas malgré
l'actualité récente
la véritable difficulté pour celui qui
en est victime d'obtenir la
reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle
beaucoup beaucoup de progrès sont
attendus sur ce sujet soit ces maladies
sont chroniques elles apparaissent 10 20
30 ans après l'exposition au risque où
elles apparaissent même sur les
générations suivantes
dans ce cas comme pour le tabagisme
finalement le risque est un risque
lointain diffus aléatoire pour
l'utilisateur donc plus difficiles à
cerner plus difficile à admettre plus
difficile à dire est plus difficile à
relier aux véritables causes
enfin les maladies qui apparaissent en
nombre aujourd'hui parkinson alzheimer
cancer de la prostate cancer du sein
sont le résultat de nombreuses années de
pratique sans information réelle sur le
risque sans protection réelle à l'expo
logis de molécules souvent retirés du
marché et qui ne prennent pas en compte
les progrès réalisés depuis quelques
petites années seulement
aussi avons-nous l'ardente obligation de
veiller par des autorisations de mise
sur le marché conforme au risque et la
définition des conditions d'utilisation
à ce que les molécules d'aujourd'hui ne
produisent pas de nouveaux effets
sanitaires sur les exposer ou sur leurs
enfants
deuxième constatation le suivi des
pesticides
après leur mise sur le marché n'est
qu'imparfaitement assuré au regard de
leur impact sanitaire réel et l'effet
des perturbateurs endocriniens est mal
pris en compte
clairement un grand nombre des faits
sont aujourd'hui mal appréhendé madame
la rapporteure y reviendra j'en suis
certaine mais je signale ici
l'impérieuse nécessité pour l'europe de
prendre ce problème à bras le corps
définition et classification des
perturbateurs endocriniens pour les
produits phytosanitaires mais aussi pour
bon nombre de produits de consommation
plus courantes méthodes d'évaluation des
effets cocktails des faibles doses
nécessitait de retravailler les
contrôles post a et même sur le marché
troisième constatation les protections
contre les pesticides ne sont pas à la
hauteur des dangers et des risques
mon collègue alain houpert interviendra
sur cette question dans le débat
c'est un point essentiel de ce rapport
auquel il convient de donner des suites
rapides et opérationnel
quatrième constat station les pratiques
industrielles agricoles et commerciales
n'intègre pas assez la préoccupation de
l'innocuité pour la santé au recours des
pesticides les industries
agroalimentaires les distributeurs mais
aussi les consommateurs doivent être
plus impliqué dans tout le processus
conduisant à la baisse de l'utilisation
de produits phytosanitaires tâche sur
les pommes herbe sur les trottoirs
calibrage des légumes tout est
aujourd'hui standardisés normes et je
dirais presque dévitalisées pouvons nous
imaginer de revenir en arrière même
raisonnablement enfin cinquième
constatations le plan ecophyto doit être
2018 doit être renforcée sur ce point
vous me permettrez de vous faire part de
mes observations dans la grande
diversité des analyses et des opinions
auxquelles nous avons été exposés un
dénominateur commun est apparu à
l'ensemble des intervenants la place
centrale du dispositif ecophyto 2018
dix ans à diminuer le recours aux
produits phytosanitaires tout en
continuant à assurer un niveau de
production élevé tant en quantité qu'en
qualité
en effet malgré les alertes lancées par
des membres de la communauté
scientifique et des associations depuis
de nombreuses années la véritable prise
de confiance de conscience pardon de
masse en france s'est produite en grande
part grâce au grenelle de
l'environnement et sa retranscription
dans le plan ecophyto 2018
la mobilisation impressionnante qui a
suivi la mise en place de ce dispositif
concerne l'ensemble des acteurs et je
veux ici saluer les efforts réalisés par
tous en premier lieu je citerai bien sûr
les exploitants agricoles qui malgré des
réticences bien compréhensible et
l'existence d'un modèle de production
agricole encourager et ancré depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale on
peut un peu peut-être insuffisamment
encore pris conscience des dangers liés
à l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires
la parole est en train de se libérer
notamment sur l'existence de maladies
chroniques les exploitants et ce qui est
très encourageant les jeunes affirme
aujourd'hui avoir une volonté de mieux
se former de mieux se protéger de mieux
s'acheminer vers une moindre utilisation
de produits chimiques
il reste du chemin à faire bien sûr et
la valeur d'exemple sur la durée est
fondamentale à ce titre les fermes dephy
doivent continuer absolument leur
développement
mais pour que cela fonctionne nous
devons entendre
nous devons répondre également monsieur
le ministre à leur anxiété
lorsque des productions entières sont
menacées de disparition sur notre
territoire
faute de molécules à gré de techniques
alternatives faute de recherche
suffisante
je pense à cet agriculteur du
lot-et-garonne déplorant la fin de la
production de noisettes en france alors
que nous étions les plus gros
producteurs producteurs exportateurs
voici encore quelques années nous devons
entendre leur anxiété également face à
une fiscalité qui peut sous couvert
d'intentions louables favoriser les
importations parallèles les fraudes voir
le grand banditisme
véritable fléau dans certaines régions
et sur certaines productions
ce que nous avons entendu à ce sujet
madame et monsieur le ministre est
totalement effarant et je voudrais
saluer le travail des équipes de police
de gendarmerie de douane de justice la
dgccrf qui sur ce sujet doivent être
soutenus et écoutez nous devons enfin
entendre la colère légitime des
exploitants lorsque l'importation de
pays européens
les met en situation de concurrence
déloyale en faisant rentrer sur notre
territoire des fruits et des légumes
traités avec des produits interdits en
france
je veux également m'adresser aux
industriels producteurs de produits
phytosanitaires ils ont intégré dans
leurs démarches et dans leur logique
économique mondiale mondialisé le risque
de stigmatisation à court terme de leurs
produits
voir leur interdiction ils sont dans
l'obligation absolue pour pérenniser
leur activité de modifier la nature de
leurs recherches et de leurs productions
une action notable a été menée sur les
baisses de volumes sur les nouveaux
meubles mode de protection sur le
recyclage des déchets salut par exemple
l'initiative adivalor parallèlement
nombre d'entreprises du secteur
choisissent d'orienter leurs recherches
sur les techniques du bio contrôle et
les et l'évolution de molécules actives
bien sûr nous devons être encore plus
exigeant plus vigilants et ne faire
preuve d'aucune naïveté mais nous devons
travailler avec ces industries et non
contre elle
l'atelier rites et récentes sur les
néonicotinoïdes doit nous conduire à
renforcer et notre vigilance et notre
exigence mais nous ne pouvons pas fermer
les yeux sur les efforts réalisés
je veux également salué l'homme cesse
son directeur marc mortureux ces équipes
qui ont su dans des périodes difficiles
de la rgpp remettre en cause leur mode
de fonctionnement évolué très
significativement sur les questions de
transparence de lutte contre les
conflits d'intérêts prendre leurs
responsabilités sur cette des sujets
d'actualité je pense aux épandages
aériens
je pense également au programme périclès
sur les effets cocktails les landes 16
doit encore progresser
il faut pour cela lui donner des moyens
des moyens non budgétaires mais des
moyens humains qui je vous le rappelle
son supporter financièrement
par les redevances que payent les
industriels déposant les demandes
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
mais c'est probablement lagence
européenne qui doit évoluer le plus et
le plus vite en profondeur sur des
sujets brûlants de fond et de forme
reconnaissance des perturbateurs
endocriniens joly dit conflits
d'intérêts rémunération des experts
réorganisation européenne désagréments
refonte de méthodes d'évaluation pour
sortir des modèles basés sur les doses
journalières admissibles et prendre en
compte par exemple les effets dits
faibles doses
la véritable révolution est bien là
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture et
je compte sur votre pouvoir de
conviction pour en être un acteur majeur
il m'est impossible de ne pas citer
l'importance de la recherche dans son
ensemble agronomique entomologique
technique sur le matériel recherche
publique et recherche privée mobiliser
pour développer des moyens de protection
supplémentaire de nouvelles techniques
culturales deux nouvelles formulations
de nouvelle ergonomie pour les bidons
les flacons les épandeurs de nouvelles
sélections variétales probablement que
le fléchage des fonds de la recherche
publique doit être plus volontariste
probablement également que nous devons
collectivement ne nous priver d'aucun
domaines de recherche pas de
complaisance n'est pas d'obscurantisme
montrer enfin je citerai les
collectivités territoriales qui de plus
en plus nombreux stands à renoncer à
l'emploi de produits phytosanitaires ou
au moins à les réduire drastiquement
nous les encouragerons dans ce sens bien
d'autres acteurs auraient pu être cités
qu'ils me pardonnent le temps me contre
1 au regard de ces évolutions et du
chemin parcouru depuis trois ans oui
j'affirme que le plan ecophyto 2018 est
un succès qualitatif incontestable par
la mobilisation qu'il a engendrées
malgré cet élan national force est
néanmoins de constater qu'en trois ans
les résultats quantitatifs de ce plan ne
sont pas satisfaisants et que pour tous
les acteurs de nombreux efforts restent
à accomplir toute fa soyons justes et
assurons la pérennité des actions
entreprises
les mécanismes mis en place ne sont
opérationnels que depuis peu de temps
certains sont encore en cours de
déploiement aussi
un grand nombre de routes nos
recommandations se retrouve en effet
dans le plan ecophyto 2018 mais nous
avons estimé de notre devoir de les
réaffirmer avec force afin justement que
ces mesures soient pérennisés et est une
chance d'atteindre leurs objectifs
soyons ambitieux et exigeant mes chers
collègues
mais laissons nous le temps de mesurer
les résultats des actions entreprises
les cycles de changement du modèle de
production sont très longs trois années
c'est un délai incroyablement cours à
l'aune des évolutions survenues au cours
des 50 dernières années
tous les membres de la mission ont
souhaité que les propositions retenues
puissent prendre vie par exemple au
travers du dépôt d'amendements ou de
proposition de loi au fur et à mesure
des textes que le sénat aura examiné le
rapporteur et moi même avons été par
exemple reçu le 3 décembre dernier par
vous monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture et nous vous en remercions
par vous même madame la ministre de la
santé le 16 janvier dernier et nous
avions eu également une séance de
travail avec le cabinet de madame
lebranchu en charge la réforme de l'état
soyez en remercié les entrevues que nous
ont permis de considérer avec vous
quelles recommandations pouvaient être
mises en oeuvre pour terminer permettez
moi de vous dire madame la ministre de
la santé monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture que les membres de la
mission le rapporteur et moi même sommes
particulièrement heureux de pouvoir
dialoguer avec vous aujourd'hui sur les
recommandations de la mission afin que
tout soit mis en oeuvre pour que une
fois de plus la santé soit au coeur de
notre action et de nos préoccupations
tu remercies merci madame sophie primas
présidente de la mission commune
d'information dans la suite de la
discussion la parole et à madame nicole
me nicole bonnefoy rapporteur de la
mission commune d'information
bonjour
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alertés par un agriculteur victimes des
pesticides
monsieur paul françois j'ai sollicité du
président du groupe socialiste du sénat
au début de l'année 2012 la création
d'une mission commune d'information sur
les impacts et des pesticides sur la
santé
le sujet n'était pas complètement
nouveau pour le sénat alors pourquoi
remettre le métier sur l'ouvragé me
direz vous précisément parce que nous
avions le sentiment d'être là devant un
problème complexe nécessitant des
investigations poussées mais aussi parce
que nous sentions une évolution de la
sensibilité de nos concitoyens est
d'abord des premiers concernés les
agriculteurs sur les risques que font
courir les pesticides à ceux qui les
manipulent et vivent au quotidien à leur
contact dès le début des travaux de la
mission mois de mars 2012
l'étendue et la complexité du champs à
explorer son temps par une imposante il
nous fallait confronté en effet les
enseignements du plusieurs disciplines
agronomie chimie médecine biologie
toxicologie écotoxicologie expo logis
épidémiologie droit etc et rencontrer
des acteurs d'une grande diversité au
mode de pensée spécifiques et aux
intérêts parfois divergents avec la
présidente et l'ensemble des membres de
la mission nous avons décidé de
concentrer nos travaux sur les effets
des pesticides sur la santé des
utilisateurs directs soit les personnels
intervenant dans leur fabrication dans
leurs applications
les familles d'agriculteurs et les
riverains des épandages mettant de côté
les investigations sur les effets des
pesticides sur l'environnement et leur
présence dans l'alimentation pour mener
nos travaux nous ne sommes pas partis
d'une feuille vierge
nous avons pu nous appuyer sur des
rapports parlementaires ceux de l'opex
en particulier le rapport de 2010
présenté par nos collègues
claude étienne et claude gatignol mais
également les autres rapports présentés
par les sénateurs gilbert barbier en
2011 sur les perturbateurs endocriniens
catherine procaccia en 2009 sur l'emploi
de la chlordécone aux antilles et marie
christine blandin 2008 sur l' expertise
sanitaire des risques chimiques du
quotidien nous avons surtout eu le souci
d'écouté très largement l'ensemble des
protagonistes liés de près ou de loin à
la question des pesticides maintenant
près d'une centaine d'auditions et de
dégager un consensus entre nous sur le
sujet à l'issue de sept mois de travail
la mission a adopté à l'unanimité plus
d'une centaine de recommandations visant
à réorienter la politique des pesticides
en france et en europe
si l'on a coutume de dire que le risque
zéro n'existe pas tendre vers cet
objectif nous a paru devoir être le but
des décideurs publics en la matière je
me réjouis qu'une telle orientation
politique qui peut être partagé entre
tous les groupes politiques qui
composaient la mission qu'ils n'avaient
pas nécessairement au départ la même
vision de cette question n'est la même
sensibilité
c'est la preuve que le travail des
coudes des acteurs du monde économique
agricole scientifique ou de la santé
lors des auditions ainsi que les débats
entre nous peuvent produire du consensus
sur un problème qui concerne au premier
chef la santé publique
je ne vais pas devant vous effectuez la
lente et fastidieuse énumération de
toutes les recommandations de la mission
mais simplement et vous énoncer quelques
axes forts de notre réflexion et
profiter de la présence des ministres
pour poser quelques questions
premier axe de réflexion de la mission
la priorité à la santé
cette priorité a constitué le fil rouge
des investigations menées par la mission
sénatoriale
cela pourra en étonner certains mais
dans les faits à tous les stades du
cycle de vie d'un produit pesticides la
priorité à la santé est loin d'aller de
soi
je prendrai trois exemples pour
illustrer mon propos en suivant le cycle
de vie d'un produit phytopharmaceutique
avant son autorisation de mise sur le
marché dite à mm
lors de la délivrance de cette
autorisation et après cette autorisation
avant tout engagement dans une procédure
d'autorisation lors des recherches
pendant l'élaboration d'une nouvelle
molécule ou non de vos produits
les considérations de santé sont
secondaires l'essentiel est de trouver
un produit efficace sur les plantes sur
les insectes ou sur les champignons que
l'on cherche à éradiquer ces recherches
sont longues
dix ans de recherche en moyenne sur une
nouvelle molécule est coûteuse pour les
industriels qui les mène ce n'est que
dans un second temps après avoir vérifié
l'efficacité du produit que sa toxicité
pour les utilisateurs est examiné les
recherches comprennent généralement des
études toxicologiques
mais devrait aussi comprendre des études
immunologique au fond la mission a
estimé que l'évaluation des risques
présentés trois lacunes majeures elles
ne sont pas menées sur la vie entière
des animaux de laboratoire ni sur
plusieurs générations de ceux ci et les
résultats de ces investigations
relatives à la santé ne sont pas rendus
publics
notons d'ailleurs que l'âne cesse dans
son avis sur l'étude du professeur
séralini sur la consommation combinée de
maïs génétiquement modifiés traités au
roundup regretté elle même le manque
d'études à long terme dans tous les
processus d'évaluation deuxième moment
où la priorité à la santé est
insuffisamment prises en compte lors de
la haine même la méthodologie suivie
pour la délivrance d'une année même
défini une dose journalière admissible
appelé des gia dose journalière
admissible d'exposition de l'homme aux
produits en deçà de laquelle on est
censé ne courir aucun risque
or les avancées de la science ont montré
qu'il est devenu précisément
inadmissible de continuer à raisonner en
fonction de cette notion de dose décrété
admissibles puisqu'elle n'a aucune
signification
lorsqu'il s'agit de pesticides ayant
comme priorité d'être des perturbateurs
endocriniens
en effet la perturbation endocrinienne
se manifeste en fonction du moment de
l'exposition
par exemple au cours de la 7e semaine
d'une grossesse
et non en fonction de la dose reçue
cette perturbation peut même exister à
une dose infime et ne pas apparaître à
une forte dose par ailleurs quelles que
soient les précautions et les limites
propres à une substance soit un produit
chaque individu peut être soumis à un
cocktail de substances et de produits au
cours d'une seule journée de sa vie en
réalité ce sont les effets sur 700 sur
la santé de ce cocktail qu'il faudrait
évaluer même s'il faut bien convenir que
cela peut s'avérer difficile
sur ce point le groupe scientifique de
l'unité pesticides de l' agence
européenne de sécurité des aliments a
émis en 2008 un avis sur tous les types
de toxicité combiné des pesticides
elle a conclu que seuls les effets
cumulés résultant d'une exposition
simultanée à des substances ayant un
mode d'action commun était préoccupant
depuis 2009 le choix des pesticides
devant être l'objet d'un examen conjoint
est toujours en cours enfin le troisième
et dernier moment où cette priorité à la
santé nous est apparu comme
insuffisamment pris en compte correspond
à la période d'utilisation effective des
produits durant des années d'utilisation
d'un produit pesticides le suivi des
conditions et de l'ampleur de son
utilisation
pas plus que le suivi des effets
négatifs observés sur la santé ne sont
réellement effectués recensés et
exploiter pourtant les agriculteurs
doivent tenir un registre retraçant leur
utilisation de pesticides mais ses
innombrables sources ne sont pas
exploitées il existe des réseaux de
vigilance censés recevoir des alertes
sur les risques liés aux pesticides
permettant de provoquer une nouvelle
évaluation des pesticides et
potentiellement de remettre en cause des
ae même délivrer mais un rapport
administratif récent a pointé le manque
de centralisation des informations ainsi
collectées et finalement les faiblesses
de l'évaluation des risques en continu
face à cette situation la mission
d'information recommande notamment de
renforcer les obligations de remonter
d'harmonisation des informations
sanitaires de terrain par les réseaux
existants et de centraliser
informations collectées en un lieu où
les alertes puisse être donnée et les
décisions prises que ce soit à
l'institut national de la vieille veille
sanitaire ou alan cesse plus d'un siècle
d'histoire des pesticides montre que
c'est généralement plusieurs dizaines
d'années après l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché d'un produit devenu
suspect pour la santé qu'est prise la
décision d'interdiction de fabrication
de commercialisation et d'utilisation
les mêmes à ce stade plus que tardif
l'interdiction a tendance à laisser
encore du temps au temps
en prévoyant une période de restriction
de l'usagé des pesticides
d'abord dans sa commercialisation puis
dans son utilisation
avant que celui ci ne disparaissent tout
à fait du commerce tandis qu'il
demeurera durant des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années dans l'organisme
humain ou dans l'environnement l'une des
préoccupations majeures pour la santé
publique résultent de la persistance des
effets des pesticides dans le temps et
parfois dans le temps long je prends ici
l'exemple de la chlordécone aux antilles
dont il est établi qu'elle peut demeurer
plus de 700 ans dans l'environnement
la difficulté à prendre les bonnes
décisions vient aussi du fait que les
effets de l'exposition aux produits ne
se font sentir parfois que de nombreuses
années après le lien entre le produit et
la détérioration de la santé est ainsi
distendus et n'apparaît pas
immédiatement la quantification de
l'effet des pesticides est malaisé mais
le lien apparaît de plus en plus évident
ce qui permet de présumer la
responsabilité dans l'apparition de
certaines pathologies
il en va ainsi de l'arsénite de soude
interdit depuis 2003 du fait de son rôle
dans l'apparition de cancers en
particulier de cancer de la vessie
nous saluons aussi la reconnaissance en
2012 comme maladies professionnelles des
agriculteurs de la maladie de parkinson
des liens ont en effet été établi entre
l'utilisation d'insecticides aux
propriétés neurotoxiques
et cette pathologie ce qui prouve qu'en
la matière les mentalités évoluent
la mission d'information dont j'ai été
la rapporteure contribue sans doute à
cette prise de conscience de la
nécessité de mettre la santé avant tout
près de préoccupation lorsque l'on parle
de pesticides la dangerosité
ces produits étaient encore il ya peu
soignée soit minimisé leurs effets
nocifs et est trop souvent considéré
comme le résultat d'une mauvaise
utilisation voir un mal nécessaire
depuis quelques années ce point de vue
n'est plus acceptable
je m'en réjouis et souhaite que nous
améliorerons encore le suivi sanitaire
des effets des pesticides
ainsi il conviendrait de généraliser les
registres du cancer qui n'existe
aujourd'hui que dans 13 départements ces
instruments de suivi épidémiologique
serait d'ailleurs utiles bien au-delà du
seul enjeu des pesticides
partant de cette priorité à la santé la
mission d'information a ré interroger la
réglementation des pesticides
c'est là le deuxième axe notre réflexion
cette réglementation n'est pas nouvelle
et s'est même renforcé au fil du temps
avec désormais une forte dimension
européenne qui organise la mise sur le
marché des produits en deux temps un
premier temps est consacré à
l'évaluation des substances qui aboutit
à leur homologation l'harmonisation
européenne en la matière est forte car
le paquet pesticides de 2009
applicable depuis juin 2011 prévoit
désormais une homologation de l'ensemble
des substances au niveau de l'union
européenne
après un processus d'évaluation qui fait
intervenir
l'ensemble des organisations des
organismes nationaux d' expertise sous
la houlette de l'efsa le processus
garantit ainsi une vision commune des
états membres et nécessite qu'un
dialogue permanent de la communauté
scientifique s'instaure une fois les
substances inscrits sur la liste de
celles autorisées dans l'union
européenne
encore faut-il autoriser les produits
créés à partir de ces substances c'est
le deuxième temps et c'est la sphère des
firmes qui se retourne vers les
autorités nationales le paquet
pesticides à renforcer là aussi
l'harmonisation en europe en permettant
d évaluation des produits par groupes de
pays et en définissant trois grandes
zones géographiques en europe la france
fait un peu office de pays de référence
pour les évaluations de la zone sud en
s'appuyant sur l'inde cesse la mission
ne remet en rien en cause le rôle et
l'excellence technique de l'ansès mais
force est de constater que le dispositif
d'évaluation des risques liés aux
pesticides souffre de plusieurs faits
laisse d'abord il est quasi impossible
de s'appuyer sur une expertise
totalement indépendante des firmes
phytopharmaceutiques les experts
totalement hors sol n'existe pas et la
transparence exigée sur leurs liens avec
l'industrie à travers les déclarations
d'intérêt qu'ils doivent effectuer n'est
qu'un pis-aller une nouvelle loi sur la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts sera
peut-être un jour nécessaire
ensuite les données sur lesquelles
travaillent les organismes d'évaluation
sont fournies par les fillettes elles
mêmes qui ont financé et réalisé les
études préalables toute une série de
billets dans les études sont possibles
fragilisant les investigations sur
l'évaluation des risques et transforme
en quelque peu l'évaluation public en
audi du processus d'évaluation du
produit effectué par les films certes il
semble difficile d'exiger des études
indépendantes avant que les produits
soient soumis à la procédure d'un même
mais la mission a recommandé que pour
les études complémentaires exigé après
la délivrance de la m
l'ansès puisse choisir elle même les
laboratoires chargés de les effectuer en
toute indépendance
de même la mission a recommandé qu'un
réexamen complet de la mêmes puissent
être effectués non plus au moment de son
renouvellement décennale mais à mi
parcours pour prendre en compte les
effets connus en situation réelle invivo
des produits autorisés
enfin les entre les acteurs extérieurs à
l'évaluation organiser des produits sont
insuffisamment associé au processus
or une bonne expertise résulte de la
confrontation des points de vue
l'ansès ne saurait détenir seul une
vérité immuable
la mission recommande une transparence
accrue des évaluations mais aussi de
donner un statut aux donneurs d'alert le
parlement pourrait se voir dotés du
droit de saisir directement le cess de
demandes d'évaluation de réévaluation
des risques liés à certains produits ou
certaines substances car ceux qui hier
pouvait paraître inoffensif peut demain
se révéler dangereux le troisième axe de
mon propre concerne les utilisations
des pesticides car si la santé doit être
au coeur de nos préoccupations
si l'évaluation doit être améliorée il
faut aussi et surtout agir pour
maîtriser et réduire les usages le
secteur agricole est le principal
utilisateur des pesticides en france et
même dans le monde
cela n'étonnera personne c'est l'utilité
de ces produits dans la protection des
cultures contre leur ravageur qui a
conduit leur succès en france
l'agriculture consomme plus de 90% des
doses commercialisées
toutes classes de produits confondues le
marché des pesticides est loin d'être
négligeable
pesant un peu moins de 2 milliards
d'euros par an en france avec des
utilisations forte en cultures
maraîchères et fruitières ou encore andy
culture ou les achats de produits
peuvent représenter entre 5 et 10 % le
chiffre d'affaires des exploitations
certes il existe aussi des usages non
agricoles mais ceux ci sont modestes
sans être insignifiant pour autant
d'ailleurs la mission recommande une
stricte limitation des usages non
agricoles qui ne répondent pas à une
logique économique mais d'agrément car
c'est probablement sur ce segment qu'une
révolution des mentalités serait la plus
féconde
longtemps considérés comme les produits
miracles de la révolution agricole les
produits phytopharmaceutiques
comme c'est leur nom dans la
réglementation commence à être remis en
cause radicalement par l'agriculture
biologique qui décide de se passer de la
chimie minérale et ne s'appuie que sur
des traitements issus des préparations
naturelles peu préoccupantes
sans aller jusqu'à cette contestation
radicale l'agriculture conventionnelle
est aussi traversé par un mouvement de
remise en cause du tout pesticide les
pouvoirs publics à travers le plan
ecophyto 2018 lancé en 2008 ont
contribué à ce changement de mentalité
noto notons coco phyto 2018 malgré des
moyens dédiés conséquent issu d'une
fraction de la redevance pour pollutions
diffuses a pour l'instant des résultats
modestes
si l' interdiction des 30 substances les
plus dangereuses en 2008 est très
positif
la réduction des quantités globales
utilisé n'est pas au rendez vous il faut
donc monsieur min
passer à la vitesse supérieure je salue
au passage votre terme détermination à
encourager les changements pratiques
agricoles
le concept d'agroécologie que vous avez
mis en avant le 18 décembre dernier lors
du grand colloque intitulé produisons
autrement montre qu'on ne doit pas
opposer performance et protection de
l'environnement
les pesticides ne sont pas la seule voie
vers la productivité à long terme leurs
effets délétères sur l'eau ou encore la
qualité des sols peuvent avoir un effet
contraire à celui recherché initialement
en faisant chuter les rendements
notre mission ne dit pas autre chose les
nombreuses auditions réalisées de
représentants du monde agricole nous ont
convaincus que l'utilisation de
pesticides relevé aussi d'habitude
prises et qui ont la vie dure
il s'agit sans doute d'une pratique
sécurisante mais beaucoup prennent
conscience qu'il existe aujourd'hui des
alternatifs
deux exemples montrent que le changement
reste cependant un combat le premier
exemple concerne les épandages aériens
il ne touche que 0,3 pour cent la
surface agricole soit moins de 100
milles hectares et sont particulièrement
symbolique
les deux lois issues du grenelle de
l'environnement avait interdit cette
technique tout en laissant subsister
quelques exceptions or au printemps 2012
la mission althea été alertés sur le
caractère pas si exceptionnel des
exceptions nous avons été surpris de
constater que malgré l'exigence
communautaire d'une évaluation
spécifique des risques liés à cette
technique
plusieurs produits allaient pouvoir être
utilisé durant la campagne 2012 en
épandage aérien avant l'évaluation les
concernant la mission a souhaité qu'il
soit mis fin aux dérogations et
encourage l'adoption de techniques
alternatives
le second exemple concerne les
équipements de protection individuelle
communément appelé le pays
là aussi la persistance de mauvaises
pratiques montrent que la prise de
conscience des effets nocifs des
produits manipulés n'est pas encore
totale il n'était pas rare il ya
quelques années de voir des agriculteurs
effectuer leur mélange sans gants et
sans masque
nous n'en sommes plus là mais le port
des équipements le recyclage des tenues
usagers
ne sont pas encore des réflexes pour
tous les équipements eux mêmes sont ils
totalement adapté suffisamment résistant
et protecteur sur ce point la mission
estimé que d'importants progrès
pouvaient encore être faits l'obligation
faite tout agriculteur et plus largement
tous professionnels devant utiliser des
pesticides de disposer d'un certificat
délivré après une formation de deux
jours dénommé syrte et phyto est un
puissant facteur de modification des
comportements mais il faut aussi
travailler sur les circuits de
distribution des produits
la mission estime indispensable qu'il
n'y ait aucune incitation économique à
vendre plus de produits que nécessaire
en ce qui concerne les jardiniers
amateurs
la mission est favorable à une solution
radicale proscrire à terme la
commercialisation à destination des non
professionnels des produits autres que
ceux autorisés autorisés en agriculture
biologique
ce n'est pas l'abus de pesticides qui
est dangereux pour la santé et
l'environnement
comme le disait de slogan de la campagne
jardiner autrement
mais le produit lui même qui pose
problème
en attendant d'interdire son utilisation
dans les jardins des particuliers la
mission recommande d'interdire la vente
dans les commerces alimentaires et de
garantir la présence permanente d'un
conseiller vendeur formés dans les
rayons des magasins
je termine ne terminerai en formulant
aveux et c'est la saison des voeux que
la centaine de recommandations résultant
des travaux de la commission et a adopté
à l'unanimité des groupes politiques
entre en vigueur dans la réalité le plus
rapidement possible madame le ministre
monsieur le ministre votre présence
conjointe aujourd'hui au sénat témoigne
de l'intérêt porté par le gouvernement à
la santé et promet premiers contacts
pris par la présidente et moi même à
l'occasion de la remise du rapport en
vos ministères respectifs ont montré que
vous aviez à coeur de faire entrer
spontanément en vigueur de nombreuses
recommandations de la mission
mais je suis certaine que vous nous en
direz un peu plus dans quelques instants
il appartiendra ensuite aux 27 membres
de la mission commune d'information en
tant que législateur d'agir pour que les
recommandations restantes
his voir le jour c'est seulement ainsi
collectivement que nous permettront
d'améliorer la protection des fabricants
et des utilisateurs de pesticides tout
en préservant les riverains et leurs
familles d'une exposition parfois
dangereuses pour terminer enfin mon
propos je tiens à adresser mes
remerciements les plus chaleureux au
président du sénat aux présidents des
commissions aux administrateurs du sénat
qui nous ont accompagnés durant ces sept
mois aux membres de la mission
particulièrement à ceux qui ont organisé
des déplacements très instructif de la
mission dans leurs départements ayant
tous conscience que nous sommes
également des acteurs d'une réduction de
l'emploi des pesticides sur nos
territoires dans nos collectivités
certaines d'entre elles en ont déjà
supprimé le recours pure et simple
je formule le souhait que de tels
comportements se généralise rapidement
mes remerciements s'adressent aussi à
nouveau au ministre sans oublier les
personnes entendues par la mission à
paris et en province dont certaines
venues de loin et en dépit de la neige
sont présentes dans les tribunes du
public
beaucoup d'entre elles nous ont déjà
fait part de leurs réactions toujours
constructives aux rapports d'information
qui je rappelle constitue non un
aboutissement mais un point de départ
merci pour votre attention merci madame
le rapporteur de la mission commune
d'information dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à madame
marisol touraine ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre shah collègue madame la
présidente de la mission d'information
commune madame la rapporteure mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je veux tout d'abord remercié l'ensemble
des membres de la mission commune
d'information sur les pesticides et de
leur impact sur la santé et
l'environnement pour le travail tout à
fait remarquable qui a pu être mené
j'adresse mes salutations toute
particulière bien entendu à la
présidente de cette mission madame
sophie primas et à sa rapporteure madame
nicole bonnefoy ils sont les remercier
d'avoir préciser leur position au cours
de leur intervention je me réjouis que
nous ayons nous ayons pu en amont
engager un dialogue fructueux et un
travail de qualité
votre rapport est extrêmement documenté
il est riche en informations et je suis
certaine qu'il nous permettra de tirer
de nombreux enseignements en matière de
santé environnement et d'approfondir
notre réflexion dans ce domaine qui
aujourd'hui occupent le coeur de
l'actualité
vous avez choisi je m'en réjouis bien
entendu de placer les enjeux de santé au
coeur de votre réflexion et des
propositions que vous faites et je m'en
réjouis puisque nous allons lancer une
stratégie nationale de santé qui nous
amène à réfléchir à la manière
précisément dont notre politique de
santé doit mieux qu'elle ne le fait
répondre à des défis comme la qualité de
l'environnement sujet qui jusqu'à il ya
peu apparaissait comme secondaire
marginal quand il n'était pas tout
simplement ignoré la prise en compte de
l'impact sanitaire des risques
environnementaux et je dois le dire
devenu un sujet majeur et le
gouvernement a tout à fait la volonté de
d'y répondre à la hauteur de ces enjeux
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer dans
cette direction déjà l'occasion au
moment des débats parlementaires sur le
bisphénol a et nous avons indiqué que la
surexposition à des agents physiques ou
à des substances nocives devaient être
traités en priorité
vous avez fait dans le cadre de votre
mission le choix de mener une réflexion
large allant depuis le fabricant jusqu'à
l'utilisateur et le fait est que
l'impact des pesticides sur la santé
doit être abordée de façon globale en
tenant compte de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de la filière
vous avez aussi très justement élargi
votre travail aux impacts sur la santé
des familles de ces professionnels ainsi
que sur celles des livres et je ne peux
que me réjouir de cette approche globale
je suis moi-même élus de la territoire
dans lequel on trouve la diversité
l'indre et loire dans lequel on trouve
la diversité des personnes concernées
que vous avez évoqué puisqu'il s'agit à
la fois de protéger nos agriculteurs ça
n'est pas le cas dans tous les
départements par définition enfin les
agriculteurs les consommateurs et de
façon plus générale nos concitoyens la
france est le premier pays agricole de
l'union européenne et par voie de
conséquence elle est aussi l'un des
premiers utilisateurs de pesticides
entre 80 et 100 mille tonnes de ces
produits sont employés chaque année cela
débouche donc sur un enjeu majeur de
santé publique
les études relatives aux effets des
pesticides sur la santé sont
actuellement synthétisée par l'institut
national de la santé et de la recherche
médicale qu'on connaît sous son acronyme
l'inserm
cette expertise collective met en
lumière l'existence de nombreux travaux
épidémiologique
ceux ci sont parfois contradictoires car
les liens de causalité entre
l'exposition aux pesticides et
l'émergence de certains cancers sont
difficiles à établir pour autant nous en
savons assez pour agir
et pour engager une politique qui
favorise une meilleure protection de nos
concitoyens
lorsqu un doute existe et que la santé
des français est en jeu nous ne pouvons
éviter certains sujets font d'ores et
déjà consensus et plusieurs maladies
sont reconnus désormais comme maladie
professionnelle
je pense par exemple la maladie de
parkinson vous y avez vous même fait
allusion ça n'allait pas de soi
au départ mais c'est un point qui
aujourd'hui ne fait plus de discussions
vous avez conduit un travail approfondi
je ne veux pas à mon tour le résumé je
veux me concentrer sur quelques constats
qui mérite d'être souligné et qui seront
au coeur des réponses que j'entends
apporter dans le cadre de mon ministère
en lien bien évidemment avec le ministre
de l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et
de la forêt en premier lieu nous devons
approfondir la connaissance des risques
sanitaires qui sont liés aux pesticides
et poursuivre les activités de recherche
la mission encourage des programmes de
recherche qui soit coordonné et
pluridisciplinaire dans différents
domaines notamment en épidémiologie en
toxicologie en biologie ou en génétique
l'objectif est de mieux comprendre les
mécanismes d'action des pesticides et
les liens de causalité entre
l'exposition aux pesticides et les
maladies je serai particulièrement
attentive aux efforts qui seront
réalisés dans le champ de la recherche
et notamment dans trois secteurs
le premier est celui de l' expertise
collective qui est engagée au sein de
l'inserm sur les effets sanitaires des
pesticides
le second et le soin des études
épidémiologiques dont l'étude agrican
relatives aux comptes au cancer chez des
agriculteurs est particulièrement
significative
le plan cancer qui est engagée et dont
la reconduction va se faire au cours de
l'année devra prendre en compte les
contextes environnementaux enfin le
troisième secteur et celui des études de
biosurveillance qui
ont coordonné par lille weis pour
estimer les niveaux d'imprégnation de la
population à certaines substances
chimiques dont les pesticides
nous avons besoin de cette connaissance
le deuxième élément que vous mettez en
avant et l'impact de certains pesticides
sur qui a qui apparaissent comme
perturbateur endocrinien la conférence
environnementale ainsi que la loi sur la
suspension du bisphénol a dans les
contenants alimentaires rappelle à cet
égard la détermination sans faille du
gouvernement en la matière je me suis
engagé à mettre en place un groupe de
travail associant l'ensemble des parties
prenantes ce groupe élaborera d'ici juin
2013 une stratégie nationale qui nous
permettra de coordonner efficacement des
actions de recherche d' expertise
d'information du public et de réflexion
sur l'encadrement réglementaire
le troisième point sur lequel je veux
mettre l'accent et que vous avez rappelé
que le système communautaire de mise sur
le marché des pesticides repose sur la
confiance à l'égard des dossiers déposés
par les fabricants il échappe ainsi à
des procédures d'évaluation des risques
suffisamment étayée un tel cadre ne
permet pas de nous assurer que ces
produits répondent à des exigences de
sécurité sanitaire notamment selon les
conditions d'utilisation par les
agriculteurs
l'union européenne enfin les instances
européennes en l'occurrence à la
commission ont pris conscience des
failles qui existent dans notre système
d'un autre dans le système tel qu'il est
mis en place au niveau européen mais je
crois que nous allons donc pouvoir
avancer en relation avec le ministère de
l'agriculture qui est en charge des
autorisations de mise sur le marché des
produits phytosanitaires
nous travaillerons pour mieux encadrer
ces autorisations et ensuite renforcer
le suivi sanitaire de l'eau remis
sur le marché c'est à dire que les
procédures da et même d'autorisation de
mise sur le marché doivent comporter un
volet sanitaire qui soient davantage
développées enfin vous insisté sur
l'importance de mettre en cohérence les
données existantes afin de mieux
déterminer la connaissance des risques
sanitaires liés aux pesticides
la mission a jugé prioritaire je cite la
nécessité de mettre en place des outils
de surveillance de veille et
d'épidémiologie concertée unique et
efficace sur l'ensemble du territoire
la question des vigilances et je crois
que vous l'avez parfaitement et non c
est une priorité de santé publique étant
donné les enjeux pour la sécurité
sanitaire
une refonte du système des vigilances
est en cours de réalisation qui doit
aboutir dès cette année parmi ces
vigilance un projet de décret relatif à
la toxico vigilance est en cours de
finalisation
il a pour objectif d'améliorer
l'organisation de la toxico vigilance
sous le pilotage de l'institut de veille
sanitaire de développer l'information
aux autorités sanitaires et d'élargir
les obligations de déclaration des
industriels de la composition de leurs
produits
il sera fondamental de veiller à une
bonne articulation entre les risques au
travail et les risques environnementaux
au travers des différents plans par
exemple plan national santé ou le plan
santé au travail environnement et plan
santé au travail
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
veux vous assurer de ma détermination et
vous dire que vos recommandations nous
inciterons encore à mener des actions
coordonnées entre les ministères et
qu'il sera nécessaire de porter ces
enjeux au niveau européen avec une forte
volonté une charte par ailleurs
précisera les modalités de choix des
experts le processus d'expertisé ses
rapports avec le pouvoir de décision
ainsi que les cas exceptionnels dans
lesquels il peut être tenu compte des
travaux réalisés
par des experts présentant un conflit
d'intérêts à plusieurs reprises j'ai
rappelé ma volonté de faire de la
prévention des risques sanitaires
environnementaux un axe majeur de la
politique de santé
le combat qui a été mené et l'engagement
qui a été le mien pour l'interdiction du
bisphénol a dans les produits dans les
contenants de produits alimentaires en
est un exemple récent
je suis convaincu que dans le risque de
ces risques dits émergents il nous
revient d'anticiper et de travailler en
amont la conférence environnementale a
traduit cette ambition elle nous a
notamment permis de fixer des objectifs
clairs et d'établir une méthode pour
faire face aux risques sanitaires
environnementaux
la stratégie nationale de santé
permettra de donner une traduction
concrète dans notre politique de santé à
ses objectifs
je vous remercie en tout cas de votre
engagement et de votre contribution
merci madame la ministre
la par l'état monsieur stéphane le foll
ministe de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
stop monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame la rapporteure
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je vais
d'abord me féliciter de la qualité du
travail qui a été fourni
dans le cadre de cette commission qui si
je les ai bien compris a été saisie à
votre demande
faisant suite d'ailleurs à des travaux
qui avaient été conduits par le sénat
après la découverte d'un certain nombre
de cas professionnelle chez des
agriculteurs de votre département
agriculteurs que j'ai rencontrés qui ont
été victimes de l'utilisation de
molécules ou de produits phytosanitaires
et à l'occasion de cette rencontre j'ai
pu mesurer d'ailleurs de manière
concrète ce qu'était le sujet qui nous
était posée aujourd'hui collectivement
et la nécessité que nous avions à partir
de là d'engager un travail de réflexion
et surtout un travail d'action entend
glisse de l'agriculture je ne reviendrai
pas sur tout les éléments qu'à évoquer
ma collègue marisol touraine sur les
questions de la santé
ils ont été très bien décrit pour dire
qu'il y a effectivement maintenant un
certain consensus sur des relations de
cause à effet entre l'utilisation la
consommation au travers d'un certain
nombre de produits de lien avec sa dame
de cancer d'une telle genèse et de
problèmes sur la santé qui sont
extrêmement importants et qui nécessite
justement qu'on réfléchisse à pour ce
qui est le ministère de la culture un
certain nombre de grandes orientations
au fond il ya trois grands sujets qui
sont posées pour le miz de l'aviculture
le premier c'est les autorisation de
mises aux marchés c'est ce que vous avez
évoquées c'est à dire comment on met sur
le marché des produits qui sont ensuite
utilisés pour lutter contre un symptôme
de maladie
on appelle ça les a et même c'est un
sujet qui fait débat qui dépend beaucoup
aussi du niveau européen et qui
nécessite que sur ceux sur cette
question on sera capables nous
gouvernement français de prendre des
contacts nécessaires pour faire évoluer
les procédures
d'autorisation de mise en marché sujet
assez vaste d'ailleurs qui touche les
phytosanitaires en agriculture mais qui
touche aussi d'autres sujets comme ceux
liés aussi aux ogm organismes
génétiquement modifiés et la france par
les positions que la prise récemment
fait bouger aujourd'hui les europe sur
un certain nombre de sujets j'y
reviendrai mais en particulier sur tout
ce qu'on appelle des protocoles
d'autorisation et nous allons poursuivre
ce travail pour qu'on soit plus sûr dans
la mise en marché et qu'on ait cette
séparation vous l'avait dit entre ceux
qui proposent des produits et ceux qui
évaluent leurs risques la collusion ou
le conflit entre les deux pouvant
conduire à des mauvais choix et donc il
faut qu'on soit sur ce sujet là aussi
extrêmement vigilant c'est le premier
engagement
et il a trouvé sa concrétisation de sa
traduction très rapidement si je prends
par exemple cette fameuse question des
néonicotinoïdes sujet qui regroupe un
certain nombre de familles et qui a des
traductions commercial sur le colza au
travers du crise heures après un rapport
qui avait été fait au début de l'année
2012 et une confirmation parlant de
cesse le ministère de l'agriculture a
pris la décision de stopper
l'utilisation de ces produits sur le
colza et avait fait une demande à
l'échelle européenne pour qu'on puisse
étudier l'ensemble de la famille l'esa a
répondu il ya quelques jours sur cette
question en particulier sur la relation
qu'il y avait entre cette famille de
molécules et son application malheureuse
sont les abeilles
j'attends une décision de 31 janvier du
cp casa on dirais pratiquement molécules
phytosanitaires c'est simplement le lieu
où se décide au niveau européen des
propositions et discussions sur ces
sujets lors de ce cp casa la france fait
valoir la position qui a été la sienne
depuis le départ dès qu'ils arrivent et
en plus trop ce risque est avéré des
décisions extrêmement claires doivent
être prises c'est en tout cas la
position que des
rendra le gouvernement français le 31
janvier et quoi qu'il arrive
s'il ya pas de décision prise au niveau
européen nous en tirons nous mêmes les
conclusions au niveau national
détermination sur ces questions
d'autorisation de mise en marché elles
éclairent deuxième point majeur pour
l'agriculture c'est au fond est-ce qu'on
n'a pas trop utiliser de ses produits
vraie question est est ce que l'objectif
qu'on doit avoir
nous en tant que ministère de
l'agriculture ce n'est pas la réduction
du recours à ces produits différents
produits appelée phytosanitaires je le
dis aujourd'hui et je lui ai déjà dit
l'objectif du ministère de la culture et
de réduire de manière significative le
recours à ces peaux nues mais il faut
qu'on soit capable d'en tirer un certain
nombre de conclusions
le plan ecophyto 2018 qui avait comme
objectif de réduire d'ici 2018 par
définition la consommation de produits
phytosanitaires d'heure de 50% a connu
des résultats qu'on pourrait apprécier
comme contraste est contrastée parce
qu'il ya deux résultats positifs le
premier c'est que les molécules les plus
dangereuses août à gènes cancérogènes
ont été retirés à hauteur de 80% par
rapport à ce qui existe et c'est un
point extrêmement positif
2e - deuxième point positif que nous
avons constaté c'est que au travers de
ce plan ecophyto a été mis en place tout
le système et le réseau certiphyto
ecophyto qui permet aujourd'hui d'abord
deux choses une meilleure formation des
agriculteurs à l'utilisation et au
recours à ces produits c'est très
important par rapport à l'expérience
malheureuse qui a été vécu il ya
quelques années sur l'utilisation de ces
produits est le deuxième point c'est
qu'à l'intérieur de ce processus
ecophyto certiphyto on voit apparaître
aussi au sein des exploitations des
démarches agricole qui met en oeuvre la
réduction du recours à ce type de
produits et c'est ça qui est important
pour moi mais c'est ça que je voudrais
dire cet après midi c'est qu'on aura
beau se fixer des objectifs de réduction
si on ne réfléchit pas au modèle de
production de m eh bien on cherche à
réduire le recours à des produits sur
des modèles qui ont été conçus pour
recourir à des produits phytosanitaires
donc on se retrouve très vite dans un
problème où vous l'avez évoqué
d'ailleurs madame la présidente en
particulier et bien si vous dites que
vous supprimez 50% des phyto vous avez
des trous noirs des zones d'ombré sur
lesquelles on n'a pas de solution en
termes de molécules pour lutter contre
certains nombres de ravageurs et quand
on n'a pas réfléchi aux modèles de
production pour limiter les risques et
un certain nombre de maladies ou de
ravageurs et bien on se trouve avec le
problème qu'on connaît aujourd'hui c'est
à dire que l'objectif de réduction de
50% 6 il a bien fonctionné sur les
molécules les plus dangereuses il n'a
pas atteint son objectif sur la
réduction en volume de la consommation
des phytosanitaires puisque quand nous
sommes arrivés au gouvernement en 2012
c'est pas de réduction que nous avons
constaté c'est une augmentation de 2 et
demi pour soi et qui est justifié du
point de vue des agriculteurs période
d'humidité difficultés de récolte toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour
expliquer cette augmentation de la même
manière d'ailleurs sujet très important
qui est à relier avec la question de la
réforme de la politique agricole commune
le fait aussi que ce soit transformé de
plus en plus des productions d'élevage
vers des productions céréalières
engrangeant à partir de là un recours
supplémentaire aux phytosanitaires dont
il ya aussi un effet qualitative et moi
l'enjeu pour moi pour le ministère de
l'agriculture à partir de ce constat
c'est de faire évoluer les modèles de
production sur ça que c'est très
intéressé par ce qui s'est passé sur
ecophyto certiphyto c'est qu'il ya des
bases intéressantes et ça a été présenté
d'ailleurs le 18 décembre sur la
question du produisions autrement et sur
l'ambition de l'agroécologie qu'on doit
porter ensemble pour justement à la fois
garantir la capacité de production de
notre agriculture et en même temps
affirmer notre ambition en termes
écologiques parce que les deux ne
peuvent pas être toujours opposée on
doit au contraire aujourd'hui enfin
trouver la voie qui va permettre de
combiner la performance économique et la
performance écologique donc pour le
ministère sur le sur ce sujet lors d'un
tenace d'un conseil national nous avons
pris des 10
ou pour aller dans ce sens-là d'abord
conforter ce réseau certiphyto faire en
sorte qu'il continue son travail et
qu'on ait des objectifs par filière
beaucoup plus précis et aussi au niveau
régional parce qu'à fixer des objectifs
nationaux sans aucune contre et isation
dans les régions selon les filières
on finit par ne pas avoir ni les outils
ni la capacité de mettre en oeuvre cette
réduction ça c'est le premier point
paraît très important
deuxième on a évoqué bien sûr à
l'occasion de cette discussion
la question de la séparation entre le
conseil qui peut être apportée aux
agriculteurs et le fait qu'on leur vende
des produits sujet très important
il fait l'objet d'ailleurs d'une étude
du conseil général de l'agriculture et
de l'inspection générale des finances
parce que il ya aussi des questions
fiscales qui sont posées comment on peut
améliorer le sujet est allé de deux
choses l'une jusqu'à une séparation
complète entre le conseil et la vente ou
des éléments intermédiaires avec la
fiscalité qui nous permettent de limiter
ce qui peut être conçu assez simplement
en même temps vous vendez des produits
et que vous êtes payé sur la vente vous
avez plutôt intérêt à en vendre que de
ne pas en vendre
mais si on veut changer ce processus
faut qu'on ait justement des mécanismes
nouveaux c'est tout l'objet de l'étude
qui va être engagé c'était le deuxième
point vous l'avez évoqué aussi sur
toutes les pratiques qui vont sur
l'utilisation de recours sur les phyto
sanitaires en particulier sur tout ce
qui est les conditions d'utilisation les
l'habillement 1 ça a été évoqué nous
avons repris les propositions étaient
les vôtres
r je signale que sur une centaine de
pros prise propriétaire soit sentent
dépendent directement du ministère de
l'agriculture
d'ores et déjà 13 de vos propositions
sont mises en avant et l'objectif c'est
d'aller le plus vite possible pour
essayer d'avancer comme vous le
souhaitez pour aller dans le sens que
vous avez voté puis le dernier point que
je voudrais évoquer c'est la question
liée entre les phyto sanitaires la santé
de manière générale la question
alimentaire parce que ça c'est un vrai
sujet aussi on le sait sur les traces tu
le pesticide en particulier dans un
certain nombre de de production il faut
qu'on soit extrêmement vigilant
extrêmement vivement et là encore nous
avons
au niveau du ministère de l'agriculture
là aussi pris la mesure des enjeux qui
sont liées à l'ensemble de ces problèmes
et nous avons décidé là encore dans le
processus de réduction de bien n'avoir
comme perspective justement l'idée que
derrière c'est le moins de résidus
possible qu'on doit trouver dans
l'alimentation
c'est un objectif et on peut l'atteindre
il rejoint d'ailleurs sont des
phytosanitaires ce qu'on fait aussi sur
la question de des antibiotiques la
lutte contre l'antibiorésistance
véritable sujet sur des molécules
critiques qui sont utilisés aussi en le
santé humaine on a fait quelques
résultats on doit aller beaucoup plus
loin et dans ce plan là nous avons aussi
des objectifs que nous allons clairement
fixée donc je voulais vous dire à la
fois la satisfaction qui est la mienne
du rapport qui a été le vôtre
d'abord parce qu' il a suscité le débat
il a engagé des réflexions
il a surtout conduit le cdh à avoir une
position sous ce rapport si j'ai bien
compris unanimes c'est très important
ton pouvoir avancer et faire en sorte
qu'on trouve les bonnes solutions qu'on
apporte les bonnes réponses
ça concerne la santé marisol touraine
l'a dit ça concerne l'agriculture au
sens où nous avons à la fois sur les
autorisations de mise en marché sur
l'objectif de réduction du recours aux
phytosanitaires et sur les conséquences
que cela peut avoir sur l'alimentation
la hache entier que nous avons ouvert je
le disais et je vais le répéter sur les
cent propositions 63 concerne ministère
de l'agriculture
d'ores et déjà une quinzaine sont mises
en oeuvre
l'objectif pour nous c'est d'aller vers
une trentaine de plus rapidement
possible sur tous les sujets utilisation
protection réduction limitation
autorisation voilà je crois une réponses
apportées aux questions que vous nous
avez posé est en tout cas encore une
fois je tenais à saluer et à vous
féliciter pour le travail que vous avez
réalisé merci merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes
tout d'abord à madame bernadette bourzai
bonjour
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
cette introduction par nous rapporte par
notre rapporteur et madame la présidente
et la réponse des ministres déjà a déjà
très largement évoqué tous les sujets je
suis désolé je serai peut-être des
redites mais j'essaierai d'être bref
dans notre mission d'information s'est
constituée en février 2012 comme il a
été dit à l'initiative du groupe
socialiste et à la demande de nicole
bonnefoy
l'actualité récente nous avait alerté
sur les dangers des pesticides pour la
santé et sur les problèmes liés à
l'utilisation de ces produits digitaux
dont l'agriculture française et une
grande trop grande consommatrice
nous savions qu'il y avait là un enjeu
de santé qu'il fallait nous y consacrer
pleinement
et pendant sept mois nous avons pu
mesurer toute l'ampleur de ce phénomène
parfois avec des moments de stupéfaction
je pense à notre rencontre dans le
morbihan avec des personnes qui avaient
été véritablement infestée par ces
pesticides et nous avons mesuré
l'ampleur des risques et la dangerosité
des pesticides sur la santé des
agriculteurs des consommateurs des
employés de coopérative de leur famille
de et des riverains sur l'environnement
tout cela étant largement sous-évalué
comme si l'arbre sécurisant de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché la
fameuse à et même des produits phyto
fanny sanitaire cacher la forêt des
malades des pesticides il est vrai et
mes collègues l'ont rappelé que le
grenelle de l'environnement a lancé en
2009 le plan ecophyto 2018 piloté par le
ministère de l'agriculture avec
l'objectif ambitieux sur le papier de
réduire de 50 % l'usagé de ces produits
avant 1900 1018 pardon si possible et il
ajouté prudemment le plan ecophyto a
maintenant près de quatre ans je
représente le sénat son comité
consultatif de gouvernance et j'ai le
regret de constater que les résultats
sont décevants
car depuis sa mise en place
non seulement la consommation de
produits phytosanitaires n'a pas
régressé mais en 2011 l'utilisation de
ces produits a même progressé de 2 et
demi pour cent en effet le plan ne s'est
pas traduit par une baisse des ventes de
produits phyto puisque d'après luis pépé
entre 2010 et 2011 ses ventes ont
augmenté de 1,3 pour cent et en france
le chiffre d'affaires des producteurs à
augmenter de 5%
ces éléments donne la mesure des progrès
à réaliser pour parvenir à infléchir et
même inversées vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre votre volonté
cette courbe ascendante du recours aux
pesticides en france pourtant la
réduction de l'utilisation des
pesticides est indispensable pour la
santé comme pour l'agriculture et les
travaux menés par la mission n'ont pu
que nous conforter dans cette certitude
ce bilan décevant de compte ne conduit
pas à recommander d'abandonner le plan
ecophyto mais bien plutôt à favoriser
une mobilisation et une
responsabilisation de tous les acteurs
de l'amont à l'aval et à promouvoir de
nouvelles orientations assorti de
nouveaux moyens en croisant toutes les
disciplines et toutes les compétences au
niveau national comme au niveau régional
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
qu'il est important de travailler
simultanément sur les apports de la
recherche scientifique les
réglementations et les réalités de
terrain où il existe déjà depuis
longtemps des exemples d' alternatives
aux pesticides faut faire connaître ses
réussites pour donner la priorité aux
démarche vertueuse et respectueuse de
l'environnement
notre rapporteur nicole bonnefoy rappelé
à juste titre il faut parfois plus d'un
demi siècle voire plus d'un siècle pour
évaluer les effets réels d'une nouvelle
substance pesticides dangereuses pour la
santé
un siècle durant lequel les utilisateurs
les consommateurs les riverains et
l'environnement en subissent les
conséquences nuisibles et parfois
dramatiques
par comparaison n'est-il pas paradoxal
de voir que l'utilisation des
préparations naturelles peu
préoccupantes dit pnpp pourtant
utilisent
et elle depuis des siècles et qui ont
prouvé depuis tout ce temps leur
efficacité autant que leur non toxicité
que cette utilisation ne soit pas
favorisé et davantage soutenu cela passe
par l'adaptation de la procédure
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché aux
spécificités des pnpp par exemple en
minorant la procédure et le cours de ce
type d'autorisation qui demeure
extrêmement lourd et coûteux pour des
produits naturels que les industriels
n'ont pas vraiment intérêt à voir
autoriser tout autant qu il est
nécessaire d'encourager le recours aux
pnpp
il est indispensable de réintroduire
dans les pratiques agricoles les
principes de base de l'agronomie
incluant le respect la connaissance et
la préservation de la vie du sol
la rotation des cultures la présence d
l'agroforesterie et vous l'avez exprimé
monsieur le ministre la recherche de
nouveaux modèles de production pour
renouer avec ses principes de base il
faut changer de modèle agricole et
forestier et réorienter la recherche
publique effectuée par l'inra qui doit
recevoir les moyens nécessaires à ses
missions mais compte tenu du constat
effectué ne serait-il pas aussi urgent
qu utile que les missions de cet
institut soit recentrée d'abord vers la
recherche biologique
par exemple pourquoi ne pas encourager
la recherche dans ce qu'on appelle le
biocontrôle vers l'utilisation des
prédateurs naturels des insectes
nuisibles aux cultures plutôt que de
recourir à toujours plus de nouvelles
substances pesticides chimiques qui tue
indistinctement tous les insectes
nuisibles
utile ou inoffensif la surmortalité des
abeilles en est un exemple j'avais une
question à vous poser monsieur le
ministre puisque l'aide ça a émis trois
avis vous y avez répondu je vous en
remercie et je vous fais confiance pour
la suite des opérations
une autre évolution des pratiques
agricoles que je souhaite souligner et
le développement indispensable de
l'agriculture biologique à qu'il faut
fixer des objectifs pour 2020
réaliste tout en restant ambitieux mais
il faut vraiment mettre pas
c'est la vitesse supérieure dans ce
secteur là vous avez lancé la démarche
produisant autrement le 18 décembre 2012
et cette démarche a été accueilli avec
intérêt et avec succès vous avez suggéré
des pistes pour stimuler la réflexion
pour inventer de nouveaux modèles qui
considérait performance économique et
environnementale
votre projet agro écologiques comporte
et je m'en réjouis un volet lié aux
pesticides
monsieur le ministre je sais la vigueur
de votre engagement et votre volonté de
faire évoluer les pratiques je souhaite
que nos travaux et contribuent
pleinement puisque vous l'avez dit vous
avez déjà accueilli un certain nombre
des recommandations de même j'ai entendu
avec plaisir madame la ministre
s'approprier certaines propositions que
nous avons faites et sur laquelle
évidemment lesquels nous serons
vigilants car désormais correctement
informés c'est à nous qu'il revient
d'amplifier d'amplifier pardon la prise
de conscience déjà bien tardive qui
s'opèrent auprès de nos concitoyens et
d'accompagner les changements qui
s'imposent et que nous devons réussir
ensemble en fait un conclusion je
félicite mes collègues présidente
rapporteur et les sénateurs et
administrateurs qui ont participé
contribuer activement à cette mission
d'information et à l'élaboration de ce
rapport dont nous aurons à coeur de le
voir de voir appliquer les
préconisations adopté je le rappelle à
l'unanimité je vous remercie
merci madame bernadette bourzai dans la
suite de la discussion la parole est à
monsieur gérard le cam
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le travail réalisé par la mission
commune d'information sur les pesticides
et leur impact sur la santé et
l'environnement est colossal notre
présidente sophie primas et notre
rapporteur nicole bonnefoy ont fait une
présentation très complète qui montre
l'ensemble des problématiques liées à
l'usagé des pesticides en ce qui
concerne leurs effets sur la santé des
utilisateurs directs et des personnes
proches exposés la mission a dû devant
l'ampleur du sujet laissez de côté
d'autres effets négatifs des pesticides
notamment la présence de résidus dans
l'alimentation humaine ou les impacts
sur l'environnement et pour avoir lu
différents avis et études
je pense ici tout particulièrement aux
effets des insecticides sur les insectes
pollinisateurs
je sais combien ces questions sont
étroitement liés je réitère ici notre
attachement pour que ces autres
conséquences de l'usagé des pesticides
soit soigneusement prise en compte en ce
qui concerne le volet santé humaine je
partage entièrement ce qui a été dit par
notre rapporteur temps dans les constats
que dans les solutions avancées et je
reviendrai simplement sur quelques
aspects de la lutte qui s'engage
aujourd'hui afin de concrétiser la
centaine de propositions unanimement
porté par la mission réduire l'usagé des
pesticides impose des changements dans
les habitudes des exploitants agricoles
et dans les modes de production
à ce titre il est essentiel de réfléchir
sur les pratiques agronomiques
des solutions existent l'inra a par
exemple mis en place une expérimentation
mettant en parallèle des parcelles
cultivées selon des méthodes intensive
et des parcelles cultivées sans recours
aux herbicides et on arrive au constat
que cultivé sans pesticides ou presque
sans pour autant faire chuter les
rendements n'est pas une fiction
ainsi dans la station expérimentale
d'époisses en bourgogne
l'inra a comparé sur dix ans une
parcelle de référence conduite selon les
méthodes intensive traditionnel travail
décent les traitements herbicides et
cinq autres parcelles cultivées selon
différents protocoles de protection
intégrée sans labour sans désherbage
mécanique etc
l'expérience
entre l'efficacité de la lutte intégrée
par un travail raisonnée du sol une
adaptation des dates des semis des
cultures et une diversification de
l'ensemencement des parcelles cependant
le recours aux cultures alternatives
pose un problème économique liés aux
débouchés commerciaux qui ne sont pas
assurés pour les exploitants réduire la
dépendance aux pesticides c'est donc
utiliser de nouvelles pratiques
agronomiques ou en réutiliser
d'anciennes mais c'est aussi réorganiser
les filières et les marchés pour
accompagner la diversification des
cultures les débats que nous avons eus
ici sur les semences fermières prennent
tout leur intérêt dans cette volonté de
mettre en place une agriculture plus
respectueuse de la santé et de
l'environnement
comme vous le savez en station mobile de
semences de ferme le mélange de variétés
est aisée et pratiquer et permet de
diminuer significativement le recours
aux produits phytosanitaires
grâce aux sélections et aux échanges qui
existe depuis toujours entre les
agriculteurs
on a des plantes qui sont mieux adaptés
aux contraintes particulières de leur
environnement où se rencontrent de la
valeur du patrimoine naturel et du
savoir-faire des générations de paysans
qui nous ont livré des trésors de
connaissances agronomique réduire usage
des pesticides c'est également en faire
une priorité de la politique agricole
commune
il est nécessaire que la politique
agricole commune par des soutiens cible
et encourage plus fortement l'objectif
de réduction des pesticides et des
pratiques agronomiques durable en l'état
actuel des discussions la commission
propose aux tic du verdissement du
premier pilier pack d'accorder un
paiement additionnel représentant 30 %
de l'enveloppé nationale en direction de
l'agriculture biologique ou pour les
agriculteurs qui respecte de bonnes
pratiques à savoir mettre en place 7 %
de surfaces d'intérêt écologique dans
les exploitations y compris les ailes et
bosquets l'état lui les mares
diversifier les cultures pour favoriser
les rotations et enfin maintenir les
prairies permanentes
or ces exigences ont été assouplies par
l'introduction de mesures équivalentes
qui à l'heure actuelle ne sont pas
vraiment défini
peut-être pourriez-vous nous en dire
davantage monsieur le ministre nous
sommes un peu inquiets car jusque là la
pac à favoriser une agriculture
intensive fortes consommatrices de
traitements chimiques contre les bio
agresseurs
réduire les pesticides c'est ce qu'ont
forte aux intérêts mercantiles de
l'industrie chimique
cela fait déjà plus de quatre ans que le
plan ecophyto 2018 est en place avec un
objectif de réduction de 50% de l'usagé
des pesticides
une réduction qui devrait porter à la
fois sur les volumes et sur la toxicité
des molécules et pourtant l'utilisation
de produits phytosanitaires reste en
hausse +2 6% en 2011
les enjeux économiques sont
considérables et malheureusement freine
les objectifs de protection de la santé
de l'environnement
je pense ici à l'avis récent de
l'autorité européenne de sécurité des
aliments
le fsa qui reconnaît les effets néfastes
sur les abeilles de trois matières
actives présente dans des insecticides
de la famille des fameux néonicotinoïdes
dans le même temps une publication du
forum est molle pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture financé par bayer crop
science et saint-jean ta défend quant à
elle les n'écoute les néonicotinoïdes le
rapport indique que je cite sur une
période de cinq ans l'union européenne
pourrait perdre près de 17 milliards
d'euros
cinquante mille emplois dans l'ensemble
de l'économie et plus d'un million de
personnes engagées dans la production
arabe en souffrirait fin de citation
on comprend bien pourquoi les grands
groupes de l'agrobusiness tente
d'associer semences et traitements et
d'interdire le droit de ressemer sa
récolte
dans ce contexte nous sommes
particulièrement attachés aux
propositions de la mission d'information
visant à je cite le rapport d'éviter le
brouillage provoquée par les conflits ou
les liens d'intérêts et d'organiser un
contrôle public effectif de l'innocuité
des pesticides autorisés envers la santé
il est essentiel de séparer la
prescription et la vente de pesticides
d'assurer des expertises indépendantes
dépourvu de tout lien avec les intérêts
privés concernés par les sujets traités
il est fondamental d'organiser
l'effectivité du contrôle public sur les
pesticides autorisés et bien sûr
d'encourager la recherche publique
à titre d'exemple direction de
l'environnement du conseil général des
côtes d'armor note dans son dernier
numéro la présence de deux substances
interdites dans nos cours d'eau
c'est le principe ces substances étant
le diuron et l'atrazine ensuite je vous
aborder le volet social et notamment la
prise en compte de la protection des
travailleurs agricoles
premier point la reconnaissance des
maladies professionnelles en agriculture
a pris du retard les maladies
professionnelles liées aux pesticides
reconnu dans le régime général devrait
l'être dans le régime agricole
sur ce point le gouvernement peut agir
très vite
il s'agit simplement de compléter une
liste peut-être pourrez-vous nous donner
des précisions sur les intentions du
gouvernement à ce sujet second point il
est important d'accorder une attention
particulière aux salariés agricoles qui
comme vous le savez sont très souvent
dans une situation de précarité
l'exemple costarmoricain des salariés de
triskalia montre combien le parcours
juridique des victimes d'intoxication
est long et difficile
50% du travail salarié agricole et du
travail saisonnier
ces salariés sont particulièrement
exposés aux pesticides du fait d'une
sous-évaluation des risques liés aux
pesticides à la non-conformité des
machines notamment servante à l'épandage
ou à la vétusté des équipements de
protection quand ils existent ils
travaillent souvent juste après
l'épandage de pesticides
parfois même sous un épandage aérien or
comme cela nous l'a été dit pendant les
auditions
les études sur la dangerosité montrent
que les personnes qui travaillent dans
ces conditions sont les plus exposés les
salariés agricoles recruté par l'office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration est maintenant de plus en
plus par des sociétés étrangères
d'intérim agricoles sont encore plus
fragilisés
d'abord il ne connaît généralement pas
leurs droits le rayonnement et les
modalités d'embauché dans le cas de
l'intérim rend difficile les contrôles
de l'inspection du travail
cette pratique du travail sans
travailleurs qui se généralise au nom de
la rentabilité est particulièrement
grave en termes d'impact sur la santé de
ces femmes et ces hommes
comment protéger ses salariés qui
parfois ne savent pas lire
c'est un challenge lorsqu'on connaît
déjà les lacunes dans l'information des
salariés nationaux
je pense ici par exemple au document
unique d'évaluation des risques pourtant
obligatoire il est souvent inexistant
sur les exploitations agricoles
de plus comment suivre ses salariés sur
le long terme
comment leur assurer une protection
sociale quelle prise en charge
lorsqu'ils lorsqu'il déclare des années
plus tard les maladies professionnelles
enfin ce sera mon dernier point
je me réjouis de ce que je considère
comme une évolution très positive au
regard des débats qui avaient eu lieu
ici en décembre 2011 sur le périmètre de
l'action de groupe
en effet le rapport reconnaît l'intérêt
d'un tel dispositif pour la protection
de la santé
face aux dangers des pesticides c'est
pourquoi fort de ce consensus
nous allons déposer sur ce sujet une
proposition de loi qui reprend le
dispositif voté au sénat proposait
d'ailleurs par la sénatrice nicole
bonnefoy mais qu'il élargit à des
litiges autres que ceux du droit à la
coupe de la consommation ou de la
concurrence je vous remercie
merci monsieur gérard le cam la parole
est à monsieur henri tandonnet
jours
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre
madame la rapporteure madame la
présidente chers collègues
c'est vrai que notre mission a été
passionnante je ne rappellerai pas les
chiffres illustrant l'importance notre
travail et tout particulièrement celui
de notre rapporteur nicole bonnefoy de
notre présidente sophie primas je tiens
à saluer l'ambiance fait d'entente
d'écouté des changes dans laquelle nous
avons mené nos travaux et quand étaient
encadrés par une équipe administrative
particulièrement motivés pour les
sénateurs de la mission il s'agissait de
s'immerger dans un sujet extrêmement
technique est vaste pour parvenir
ensuite à une analyse partagée de la
situation et à des préconisations utile
nous avons donc concentré orienter notre
attention sur les personnes en contact
direct avec les substances et produits
pesticides qu'ils soient riverains de
l'industrie de l'agriculture épandeur
professionnels paysagistes particuliers
ou encore salarié de collectivités le
but de mon intervention n'est pas
d'exposer l'ensemble des problèmes ou
recommandations nous avons pu formuler
mais plutôt d'insister sur certains
enjeux que j'ai jugé essentiel en
premier lieu un constat sur le terrain
une dépendance aux pesticides encore
forte
ensuite l'absence de garantie pour le
consommateur sur la qualité des produits
commercialisés et les distorsions de
concurrence intra et extra
communautaires et pour finir des outils
de prévention à mettre en oeuvre les
lanceurs d'alert et l'action collective
tout d'abord je souhaite rappeler que ce
rapport est un travail engagé sous
l'angle de la santé il n'est aucunement
un procès fait à l'aviculture et ne
préconise pas ce qu'elle doit être
beaucoup d'efforts sont faits par les
agriculteurs depuis plusieurs années
pour réduire la dépendance aux
pesticides notamment à travers le plan
ecophyto 2018 ou encore avec la
formation certiphyto et ce pour
atteindre une agriculture toujours plus
raisonnée nous avons relevé une
évolution vers plus d'un gros vus au
logis sous
du soin de la plante et de la terre -
d'épandage chimiques
mais cet exercice faire la réduction de
pesticides reste pourtant difficile il
est encore culturel chez les
consommateurs des habitudes liées à
l'apparence se sont installés nous ne
souhaitons pas trouvé depuis seront dans
les salades de l'image dans les haricots
verts il en va de même pour les tâches
sur les fruits qui ne sont pas acceptés
quand on interroge les agriculteurs qui
travaillent pour les grands groupes de
transformation alimentaire
nous constatons que nous constatons que
les exigences sont extrêmement précises
pour la production industrialisée les
auditions que nous avons procédé lors de
la mission n'ont cessé de nous rappeler
ces réalités sur le terrain les dangers
de toutes origines menace les récoltes
l'apparition d'un insecte ravageur la
drosophile de suzuki l'an dernier a
durement touché les fruits rouges
notamment dans le lot-et-garonne pour
les frères les fraises sous serre ceux
qui ont abandonné le label biologique et
son passé un traitement chimique ont
sauvé leur production mais sans
insecticide il était impossible de
réagir devant cet insecte émergents
votre exemple entendu durant nos travaux
un agriculteur travaillant pour une
grande marque commerciale a été obligée
d'importer des salades d'espagne en
pleine saison
allaire alors qu'en matière de lutte
contre le puceron de la salade
la réglementation française impose une
distinction entre les différents types
de salade laitue batavia match alors que
le reste de l'union européenne s'en
tient au terme générique de salades
ainsi en 2011 la coopérative pour
laquelle travaille cet agriculteur a
perdu plusieurs millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires faute d'autorisation
d'utiliser des produits de lutte contre
le plus sont les situations évoquées
précédemment illustre certaines réalités
auxquelles font face les producteurs
la réduction des pesticides vers
laquelle nous essayons de tendre en
france et source d'importantes
inquiètante distorsion de concurrence
mais surtout ces disparités dans les
législations ne permettent pas ce jour
d'apporter de garanties et
d'informations claires aux consommateurs
quant aux produits vendus à cet égard il
faut distinguer
disparités que nous rencontrons avec les
pays extracommunautaires
à mon avis il est inacceptable que l'on
puisse importer des légumes qui ont été
traités avec des produits interdits dans
notre pays dans l'union européenne
depuis des années l'objectif
d'interdiction de commercialisation de
tels produits agricoles en france doit
être fixé sans cela la politique
sanitaire nationale n'aura aucun effet
ne pourra pas être lisible avec les
états membres de l'union européenne
depuis l'adoption du paquet pesticides
il y à une amélioration très nette et un
encadrement de plus en plus strictes au
sein de l'union européenne
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre
cependant il demeure indispensable de
réviser les modalités de coopération
transfrontalière intra européennes car
noël sont souvent plus restrictive que
la directive et pénalise donc les
produits français les producteurs
français
en bref aujourd'hui des produits
agricoles peuvent être commercialisés en
france en ayant été traités en amont
dans d'autres pays par des pesticides
dont l'utilisation est interdite dans
l'hexagone si rien ne change on ne
trouvera plus sur nos étals que des
séries étrangères parce que nos
autorités tardent à l'homologation de
telle ou telle molécule pourtant agréé
au niveau européen monsieur le ministre
de l'agriculture on vous a interpellé
cet automne sur le problème de la
conservation des pommes qui sont traités
au portugal par des produits interdits
en france
ces pommes se retrouve sur nos étals
français donc il ya urgence harmoniser
les procédures d'autorisation de mise
sur le marché
de plus nos producteurs français ne
peuvent tirer avantage de leur usage
modéré de pesticides
en effet quand ils font de la publicité
collective réalisée en partie ou en
totalité par des fonds européens et
n'ont aucunement le droit de mettre en
avant leur label france et la qualité
qui en résulte un autre aspect doit être
également renforcer la coopération
transfrontalière en matière de fraude
comme lundi que le rapport actuellement
les services voient leur action gêné par
la combinaison de deux facteurs
distingue le principe de la libre
circulation des marchandises au sein de
l'union européenne
elat uni dont font preuve les autorités
du pays
le système européen d'alerté rapide pour
les denrées alimentaires et les aliments
pour animaux
dix systèmes sort d'anne basé sur le
règlement 178 2002 du parlement européen
peut constituer un exemple à suivre
puisqu'il a démontré son utilité en
matière de fraudes alimentaires avec des
commissions rogatoires exécutées dans
des délais records ces modalités
pourrait être appliquée à la lutte
contre la fraude à la législation sur
les pesticides
cela nécessite nécessiterait sans doute
l'élaboration d'un nouveau règlement
mais sur cet exemple efficace le dernier
enjeu que je vais vous évoquerez et
celui de renforcement du renforcement
des actions d'encadrement de régulation
et de lutte contre les fraudes de l'
usage des produits phytosanitaires
grâce à des outils de prévention nous
devons veiller à ce que les lanceurs
d'alert acteur essentiel pour
l'identification des atteintes à la
santé puissent bénéficier d'une
protection juridique solide
cette production cette protection est
certes engagés au plan international
comme en droit français
mais la logique doit désormais être
poussé à son terme voilà pour le débat
sur les pesticides et leurs effets sur
la santé et l'environnement
un débat qui fait suite à un rapport de
la mission commune d'information sur les
pesticides
intitulé pesticides vers le risque zéro
un rapport qui a été élaboré en octobre
2012 pour trouver des moyens de réduire
l'usagé des pesticides dans
l'agriculture en france mais aussi plus
largement en europe
vous pourrez le revoir à tout instant
sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à tous sur public
sénat
démis phrase qu'on a